[Music]
on this Thursday night picket lines
across the country
[Music]
well the demands from federal workers
for more pay and more flexibility as
important Services remain at a
standstill
the promise to plant two billion trees
why only a fraction are in the ground
and Canada is still falling short on
climate action shot after making a
mistake the bullet came back and it hit
me and the bullet was in my cheek the
rash of unarmed Americans caught in gun
violence is no place safe and the Maiden
flight of one of the most powerful
Rockets ever built
oh why the SpaceX Starship blew up but
is still considered a success
snow with Donna freezing good evening
and thanks for joining us tens of
thousands of federal workers are back on
the picket lines for day two of their
strike bargaining is still underway
between the union the public service
Alliance of Canada and the federal
government but there are no signs of a
deal there has been no contract since
2021. one of the demands is a guarantee
about the right to work from home
employees have been mandated back to the
office at least two days a week this is
an issue employers across the country
are grappling with and why so many eyes
are on the outcome of this strike turia
isri has our top story tonight
foreign
federal workers are on the picket line
and the front line of a deepening debate
you don't have to be in an office do
your job well negotiations between the
government and the public service
Alliance of Canada are at an impasse
union members are fighting for more
money and more flexibility and they want
remote work written right into their
contracts we want to see language
incorporated into the correct Collective
Agreement that reflects working from
home the treasury board ordered civil
servants back to the office for at least
two days a week I'm at my desk on my
computer for a lot of the day a lot of
it's me reading through documents so
that's just not something I need to come
in to do we are still dealing with the
covid-19 pandemic and it can put our
lives at risk to be in the office but
the feds and some Business Leaders
believe it is time to come back downtown
course has suffered for the past two
years through covid and they're not back
to pre-pandemic revenues it's a
conversation happening at workplaces
across the country public and private
while many employees insist remote work
saves time and money some employers feel
like they're losing out certainly a lot
of my clients who have expressed a
desire to get everybody back in the
office full time again like the
pre-pandemic days the big reason for
that being partially productivity but
also the collegiality Alexandra Samuel
is a digital workplace expert who wrote
the book on remote work we see in study
after study that everybody who's had the
opportunity to work remotely over the
pandemic is pretty Keen to keep that
opportunity Samuel believes it's not
unreasonable to ask workers to return to
the office but the approach can't be one
size fits all managers have this strong
pull to bring people back to the office
because that is for the most part how
they know how to manage but the truth is
that's not everybody's strong suit the
outcome of these negotiations could set
the tone for similar labor disputes
happening across the country about
whether employees have the right to work
from home
Taria is read Global News Ottawa
police say they're investigating a major
Heist from Toronto's Pearson
International Airport 20 million dollars
worth of gold and other high-value goods
were stolen after being offloaded from
an aircraft police say the plane landed
early in the evening on Monday and that
after what they call a high value
container was secured at a holding
facility it was stolen the gold and
goods were reported missing a short time
later
there was a bold promise made two years
ago by the federal government to plant
two billion trees by 2031. part of a
strategy to reduce the impact of climate
change trees absorbed carbon dioxide and
reforestation is widely seen as an
effective strategy but an audit of the
program by Canada's environment
commissioner says so far we are nowhere
close to getting 2 billion trees in the
ground and as David Aiken reports the
commissioner found other holes in the
Trudeau government's green agenda
what we're going to do is plant two
billion trees over the next decade it
was one of the signature elements of the
Liberals campaign platform in 2019 a
promise to plant trees that will suck
harmful greenhouse gas emissions out of
the air but a new report from
parliament's environment commissioner
Jerry DeMarco says that unless Ottawa
radically changes the way the tree
planting program works there's no way to
hit that goal of planting 2 billion
trees in a decade they are not on track
and we provide recommendations that
would allow them to get back on track to
meet two billion trees by 2031 so it's
still possible to catch up and it's not
just that the promised environmental
benefit of planting all those trees may
not be as advertised those Returns on
investment will come in later decades as
the trees grow larger
and there are other gaps in the
government's green agenda for example
the government has passed lots of
regulations to cut greenhouse gases the
rule on vehicle tailpipe emissions is
one good example but Ottawa cannot say
how effective each regulation has been
DeMarco says that failure is the latest
in two decades of Canada failing to
deliver on climate change promises there
is no track record of Canadian emission
reductions there's only been a track
record so far of increases in greenhouse
gas emissions so we're improving every
year but we won't stop fight climate
change while we figure out reporting
methodologies DeMarco had one more
warning he says climate change poses
real risks to the stability of Canada's
financial sector and that the Federal
Banking regulator needs to do more to
make sure financial institutions are
accounting for that risk David Aiken
Global News
Ottawa
recognizing the risks and adapting to
climate change is going to be essential
and a new report looking at Europe puts
that into context it says extreme heat
and drought is threatening lives and
livelihoods especially in southern
Europe which is warming nearly twice as
much as the globe on average since
pre-industrial times new modeling
compiled by Europe's leading climate
change service shows 2022 was Europe's
hottest summer on record and the
continent's second warmest year globally
it was the Earth's fifth warmest year on
record the report suggests the return to
El Nino conditions later this year will
likely drive up temperatures in 2023 or
24.
climate change isn't a future problem it
is a current problem there or a current
challenge that we all need to adapt to
and live with
the last eight years have been the
warmest ever recorded on earth the
world's hottest year on record was in
2016 that was fueled by a strong El Nino
weather phenomenon millions of Americans
in the central U.S are under threat of
severe weather yet again and at least
two people are dead after tornadoes
ripped through central Oklahoma
overnight rescue workers are combing
through flattened homes after reports of
people trapped and injured the tornado
the touchdown there was one of 18
spotted in Oklahoma Iowa and Kansas and
the threat still exists for a second
consecutive day tornado and severe
thunderstorm watches are in effect for
about 40 million Americans
there are more guns than people in the
U.S and Trauma from gun violence is on
the rise last weekend was the most
violent of the Year an American
non-profit group that tracks gun-related
violence says there were seven mass
shootings on Saturday alone one of them
was at a 16th birthday party in Alabama
where four people were killed 28 injured
and there have been multiple cases of
unarmed people being shot after
accidentally making a wrong turn or
ringing the wrong doorbell Mike
Armstrong takes a deeper look at
America's persistent problem with guns
we just never expected it in a million
years it started over a basketball that
rolled onto the wrong lawn the homeowner
went inside and came back with a gun one
of four people shot Tuesday in North
Carolina was this six-year-old girl the
bullet came back and it hit me and the
boy went in in my seat Andrew Lester
entered the courtroom in Missouri this
week an 85 year old man was charged
after a shooting involved having a 16
year old boy police say Ralph yarrow
went to this home and was shot through
the door he was supposed to pick up his
brothers and had simply gone to the
wrong house a very sad case it was a
similar mistake in New York state
Saturday a group of friends drove up a
rural driveway to turn around and were
shot at twice one of the bullets killed
20-year-old Kalyn Gillis for this man to
sit on his porch and fire at a car with
no threat
is just
angers me so badly I'm Peyton Washington
on Woodlands Elite Generals in Texas an
18 year old cheerleader is in hospital
she and a friend were shot Tuesday in a
supermarket parking lot leaving practice
when one of them tried to get into the
wrong car he shot his gun like five
times or so a recent Gallup poll found
63 percent of Americans are dissatisfied
with the country's laws and policies on
gun control that includes a majority
among Republicans 54 even if the
National Rifle association's annual
convention this past weekend there was
some support for tightening rules I
think we need to have more control over
who gets to purchase the guns this is a
mental health problem well the loudest
voices at the convention were pushing in
another direction as though the U.S has
a bigger problem with mental health than
other countries like Canada it does not
what it does have is more weapons per
capita than any other country and a
culture that says people need a gun for
protect action these latest shootings
are indicative of the ramifications of a
gun lobby doing everything they can to
self-fear in order to sell guns
Farmington Police now more guns doesn't
make it easier for police either this
was the case earlier this month in New
Mexico police were responding to a
domestic violence report in the middle
of the night hey handsome the homeowner
went to the door with a weapon in his
hand and was shot and killed shot fired
shots fired police in that case had also
gone to the wrong home Mike Armstrong
Global News
criminal charges against American actor
Alec Baldwin over the fatal shooting of
a cinematographer have been dropped it
happened in October of 2021 in New
Mexico on the set of the western rust
Baldwin and the film's armorer Hannah
guterres Reed were charged with
involuntary manslaughter in the death of
Helena Hutchins both pleaded not guilty
Baldwin's lawyers say they are pleased
with the decision to dismiss the case
against him and encourage a proper
investigation into the circumstances of
what they call a tragic accident Baldwin
was rehearsing with a pistol when the
gun went off killing Hutchins and
wounding the film's director
another BC first nation is reporting the
discovery of unmarked Graves at the site
of a former residential school and a
warning some of the details in the story
are distressing the shishal nation on
BC's Sunshine Coast says it's found 40
unmarked children's Graves at St
Augustine's residential school in
seashelt researchers use ground
penetrating radar to find them and
believe there could be more
these children
were our aunties they were our uncles
they were our future leaders that we
never met
the nation says the ground where the
school used to be has been Disturbed
over the years so researchers also
relied on interviews with survivors the
she shall nation is the latest of
several First Nations in recent years to
announce the discovery of what they
believe are unmarked Graves at the sites
of former residential schools a 24-hour
crisis line is available for anyone
experiencing pain or distress as a
result of their residential school
experience you can call toll-free and
speak in confidence 1-800-721-0066
the federal government has approved a
major port expansion in southern British
Columbia the Roberts bank's Terminal 2
project proposed by the Vancouver Fraser
Port Authority will increase the
existing port's capacity by 50 percent
it's expected to create hundreds of jobs
the approval comes after extensive
consultation with local communities and
Indigenous groups an independent review
panel also conducted an environmental
assessment there are hundreds of Legally
binding conditions to help protect the
environment including habitat creation
programs for birds and infrastructure to
help the flow of fish along with funds
designated for those protections
to get to project approval was a high
bar to me and so it should be and today
we are announcing approval of the rbt2
project subject to
373 legally binding conditions the
Vancouver Fraser Port Authority must
also put in place a 150 million dollar
Financial guarantee to ensure funds are
available for the first three years of
construction to comply with these
legally binding conditions
275 billion dollars worth of trade
passes through the Vancouver Fraser Port
Authority each year
a pivotal visit for Ukraine coming up
why the NATO leaders trip is bringing
some hope to the war ravaged country
[Music]
in Yemen's Capital an investigation is
underway into a crush of people that
left at least 78 people dead at a
charitable event during the final days
of Ramadan and a warning the images are
disturbing
[Applause]
shows the moment it happened hundreds of
people tried to flee and yelled for help
the crowd had gone to a school to try to
receive Aid donations worth about nine
dollars a person people in Yemen are in
desperate need the country has been
devastated by an eight-year Civil War
that has killed tens of thousands of
people crippled the economy and pushed
Millions to the brink of starvation
in Sudan thousands of people have fled
ongoing violence in the capital city of
Khartoum and they're desperate for a
temporary ceasefire over Eid the holiday
marking the end of Ramadan
residents boarded buses and droves
grabbing what they could carry as
fighting between rival military factions
entered its sixth day multiple
ceasefires have so far failed Food
Supplies are becoming scarce about 6
million people live in the capital area
of Sudan where the fighting has been
most intense
NATO's Secretary General Yen stoltenberg
made a surprise visit to Kiev today his
first since Russia launched its
full-scale invasion of Ukraine
in his strongest remarks yet stoltenberg
says Ukraine has a rightful place in
NATO and the issue of membership he said
would be high on the agenda at the NATO
Summit in July there's still no road map
or time frame for Ukraine to join the
military Alliance today Russia
reinforced its goal to prevent Ukraine
from joining NATO stoltenberg agreed to
more support for Ukraine he also laid a
wreath in memory of those who have been
killed during the Russian occupation of
bucha more than 1400 people died
including 37 children
[Music]
Successful Failure ahead why scientists
celebrated the blowing up of Elon musk's
SpaceX Starship
[Music]
you can't quibble about whether it was a
successful launch but it's a good thing
no one was on board Elon musk's SpaceX
Starship did lift off today but about
four minutes later experienced what the
team calls a rapid unscheduled
disassembly that means it blew up at 120
meters high Starship is the biggest most
powerful rocket ever built it's taller
than NASA's Saturn V used for the Apollo
Mission and twice the size of the Space
Shuttle it's intended to one day send
people to Mars but as Jackson prosco
reports they're going to have to work
out a few Kinks first
no Rockets so big or so powerful has
ever done this with 33 engines and 4 500
tons of fuel the SpaceX Starship soared
off the launch pad
graceful thrust of a Saturn flying
heading to space it made it high above
the Gulf of Mexico on its way into test
orbit but just minutes into the launch a
problem you can see some of the engines
failed and right before Starship was
supposed to separate from its booster it
all went sideways obviously we're seeing
from the ground cameras the entire
Starship stack continuing to rotate we
should have had Separation by now
Starship started spiraling and then
[Applause]
just experience what we call a rapid
unscheduled disassembly it doesn't take
a rocket scientist to know what that
means not great
but not terrible SpaceX staff actually
celebrated while SpaceX founder Elon
Musk watched from mission control
everything after clearing the tower was
icing on the cake
starship's huge size has brought big
challenges multiple tests have failed
spectacularly the company insists each
attempt good or bad brings it closer to
its lofty goals the SpaceX is hoping to
carry humans to much further distances
inside our solar system a lot more
humans at one time and uh and also do it
much more cost effectively liftoff we
have a liftoff like the Apollo missions
before it it's hoped Starship will one
day take people back to the moon for
NASA and maybe Mars unlike Rockets of
the past Starship and its booster are
meant to land and be reused they'll get
another booster and another Starship and
they'll try again indeed SpaceX plans to
analyze the data from this Successful
Failure and aims to send another
Starship into the heavens in the coming
months Jackson crosco Global News
Washington
[Applause]
[Music]
if you've been through the Calgary
International Airport you've likely seen
the pair of towers with giant spinning
tin planes the sculptures have been a
colorful part of the domestic terminal
for 20 years now as Heather York's West
explains the airport is updating the
terminal and returning the art to the
artist whose hopeful the planes can find
a new home
around Alberta his works of art are well
known
Jeff de Boer is a sculptor and over the
years he's created more than 3 000
pieces they're nostalgic whimsical
and usually made of metal but ask him
his favorite
well this is absolutely at the top
absolutely at the top for more than two
decades his piece called when Aviation
was young has been a fixture at the
Calgary International Airport two giant
wind-up toys featuring Larger than Life
tin planes yeah they've been there a
really long time I remember when they
were there we used to fly here as a kid
and see grandparents and now these girls
play with them when we're here they like
to twist them up and see the planes go
around but the artwork will soon be
departing YYC that terminal building can
no longer meet its its requirements for
seeding to be quite honest they have to
rebuild or redesign that space and so
many things have to be taken out now to
make room for people so the installation
that came together over 5 000 hours more
than 20 years ago is searching for a new
home
and at more than six meters tall that's
no easy task the 17-piece set also has
to remain indoors and requires regular
maintenance as well but 24 hours ago I
wasn't sure what was going to happen but
the last 24 hours has been absolutely
electric from shopping malls museums and
University campuses the interest in this
artwork so far has been strong so
there's there's lots of opportunity and
possibilities coming down the pipeline
now for the work so I'm very confident
that we're going to be able to keep this
in Calgary
so the flights of imagination can
continue for the next generation of kids
and Beyond Heather urich's West Global
News Calgary
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
here in Canada is these cherry blossoms
in Toronto's High Park many of the trees
are 60 years old they were a gift from
the Japanese ambassador to Canada thanks
for watching para NASA will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and I'll see you
Saturday for the new reality bye-bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]